[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'empêche dans le film c'est parce que
les humains ont fait des expériences sur
les singes qui sont mutés qui sont
rebellés et s'il a fait l'expérience sur
d'autres animaux
[Musique]
depuis quand vous voulez complémentaires
ça a toujours été notre objectif mais
[ __ ] ça j'en étais sûr moi mon chien a
toujours un regard george v toujours
défoncé genre comment oui moi j'ai
toujours rien je déchire on va chercher
donc on se casse le nez des requins on
se casse le désirera se rendra jamais
non à baisse les yeux
wallace à lens en [ __ ] de poissons des
vers solidaires aux papillons de nuit
ces jours là découle un vrai au pire
vous de voir des sais pas trop car on
est des poules deux abeilles
face à l'un des bijoux titre oh mon dieu
elle arrive par demi-douzaine c'est la
panique
deux bouteilles de vin blanc a amené de
la douzième bouteille de vin blanc
aux manettes de l'a320 savate haguenau
[Musique]
attendant c'est juste une promenade l'un
à l'est aussi en fait pas de photos la
bonne journée dès lors me manque la
sauce salée en vrai le plus steve essart
est n'a pas aidé sa cause en soit c'est
ça
j'avais passé un quelqu'un a peut-être
qui sent seul bon
[Musique]
benoît